the days leading up to prince philip's
passing would have no doubt been
difficult for the queen who of course
knew that he came back from the hospital
after a very serious health struggle in
fact it was very interesting for us
observing to see buckingham palace go
from giving regular updates
on prince philip's condition to giving
no updates at all
and i think in that moment when we saw
him travel back to windsor castle to be
reunited with the queen there were many
that thought that it could be
his final days and i think what's so
great about that for a couple that spent
73 years married together a very happy
marriage they were really each other's
sidekicks
throughout all of this she may have been
the head of state but he was there
supporting her every step of the way and
as a family they were very much equals
and so this would have been a really
beautiful time for them to remember
all of the things that they've achieved
together and for him to really
celebrate and be happy with the life
that he had lived
it would no doubt be a very difficult
time for the queen now who is
for the first time in many years
completely alone but what she does have
is a very large family many
grandchildren great
grandchildren who are all there for her
in her time of need this has been a
moment that i think for many royal
family members they would have been
gearing up to of course we have just
come
three weeks off prince phillips returned
from the hospital
and whilst he was of course resting up
alongside the queen at home
i think there are many that felt that
perhaps his health was in decline and so
this is a moment that i think had been a
long time coming but of course there is
a huge sense of sadness
across all the royal households today
not just amongst the royal family
members but of course by
the aides and staff that really grew to
to know prince philip as a person
and there is a genuine sense of sadness
but at the same time
a celebration of a life that was lived
to its fullest
and of course a man who was not only the
dutiful consort to the queen
but also a loyal husband of 73 years and
i think that's really what the focus is
on today from the moment prince philip's
death was announced
by her majesty herself through
buckingham palace
she went into an official period of
royal mourning but
lasts for eight days it means she's no
longer
involved with any royal matters other
than private family matters
it also means that the the government or
the country itself me
put state affairs to one side during
this period of mourning it's really
about giving the queen
her only chance to finally put family
before juicy she has lived a life where
juicy always comes first
this is a moment that she really needs
for herself and this will be something
that somewhat of a process
for her after the eight day period
there's a further 30 days of a lighter
morning period where the queen won't
carry out
official rural engagements but she will
be involved in the day-to-day
rural activities of head of state so
it's a real mix of protocol but also
real sympathy for a woman who has just
lost her husband of 73 years